smoke smoke in in force awakens is only
seen kind of as a hologram yeah and so
there's a lot of I think we have a still
here there is the trolley scene yeah
moisturise yes all I would say but and
you know so there's a lot of obviously
Star Wars fans lost their minds cuz
there were just they want to know more
about snow do you like the fact that
there's a lot of mystery around snow
willing Snoke likes there's a lot of MIS
absolutely I mean any great leader likes
a lot of mystery well actually not all
great leaders well not all leaders yes
but some leaders like Snoke you know the
leader of the first order that that
mystery helps him be more powerful and
especially you know that the the the
first order is in a shocking state as we
saw at the end of force awakens its left
in a really bad way and he is under
threatened he's full of fear and he's
under he there's a lot of fear because
there's this great feminine energy this
great female force that's coming at him
and he finds that incredibly worrying
where and where does he draw his power
from it's just from the fear he that's
what he does that's how he gets stronger
leader leaders do operate out of it cuz
where else is there to go when you're at
the top you know there's only one way to
go and so clean you know clinging on to
that power in that you know trying to
make the galaxy great again is you know
I see what you did there and it was
nicely done it's fine it went very well
snow is you know a lot of people were
wondering there's a lot of fans he's so
powerful and he's so old he's existed
existed for a long time
why was he not in the original trilogy
does anyone have to come up with that
answer
yeah well the fact of the matter is back
then I mean and this is the thing about
the secrecy about the Star Wars you know
I you know you keep all these secrets
for ages and ages and then the
merchandise turns up before you open the
movie and everybody sees what Snoke
looks like in the movie and he wears
this gold l'arme he's got a gold alarm a
robe which yes so I my theory my Snoke
theory and there are many out there is
that in younger days he was a sort of
Hugh Hefner like figure
during the first three movie it was the
late 70s seventies and he was having a
rocking time yeah you know but then
things went horribly wrong then things
weren't ready yeah he skin dry it out
and he got angry yeah
you